hi my name is George Davey and I'm a  mega Trump pan and I think I had the  best sign in the entire country it's  kind of an expression of art I wanted to  have a political sign I kind of decided  early on I've been a lifelong Trump fan  I was a fan of Trump even before he was  on television I'm originally when I put  it up I wanted to sign to me mysterious  and provocative and broke thought and  about the caucus and I I thought it was  more intriguing to people if it was  mysterious it's been vandalized a couple  times one time by some high school  students so I think they were just out  you know they had to do it but one time  by a guy that was probably not a trump  supporter